[Musique]
savez vous qu'il ya une différence entre
réussir dans la vie
et réussir sa vie pourquoi ces
différences fondamentales
tout simplement parce que chaque homme
est doté d'un potentiel qui lui est
propre et chaque personne est unique
chercher à réussir dans la vie revient à
baser sa vie sur des références externe
ses références malheureusement sont
fluctuantes fluctuante dans le temps
d'une personne à l'autre de
l'environnement à un autre ce qui fait
que chercher à réussir dans la vie peut
très vite aboutir à une course sans fin
car il n'y a pas de limite
chercher à réussir dans la vie peut nous
amener également à nous focaliser que
sur nous une autre personne sur l'eau
bien sûr mon compte bancaire sur ma
maison sur moi moi et encore mois ce qui
fait qu'on peut être très vite les
connecter de la réalité et oublier le
vrai sens de la vie chercher à réussir
dans la vie
ça peut également nous amener à oublier
que malgré que notre maison
porto 20 pièces le jour de notre mort
nous serons chacun individuellement dans
une froide qui sera à peine plus large
que nos épaules
je ne suis pas en train de dire qu'il
faut pas être riche c'est pas là le
propos je suis juste venu partager avec
vous ce qui pour moi doit être
l'essentiel d'une vie c'est pour cela
que réussir s'agit c'est basé sa vie sur
des convictions profondes
c'est basé ma vie sur des références
internes
c'est trouver la voie qui m'est propre
c'est me dire il faudrait que j'aie
backed ma génération avec des valeurs
qui tiennent dans le temps l'exemplarité
l'excellence le courage comme des six
disait le goût du travail bien fait
chercher à réussir sa vie c'est se poser
en permanence la question qu'est ce que
les gens diront de moi lorsque je ne
serai plus de ce monde
quelle histoire quelle histoire
voudrais-je écrire
quel héritage moral voudrais-je laisser
à mes enfants il n'y a pas que
l'héritage matériel qu'est ce que les
gens diront à mes enfants lorsqu'ils
croiseront dans la rue est ce que mes
enfants seront fiers de moi où est-ce
qu'ils auront entre deux maux vous savez
ma conviction profonde
ma conviction c'est que les différents
défis de notre monde d'aujourd'hui et de
demain seront résolus par des hommes et
les femmes qui cherchent à réussir leur
vie et non dans la vie car ces hommes et
ces femmes ont compris
que nous sommes plus de 7 milliards dans
le monde
mais ce sont 7 milliards de différence 7
milliards de diversité qu'un chaque
personne est unique et a une mission
particulière ces hommes et ces femmes
ont compris également que
scientifiquement il y a une chance je
dis bien une chance sur mille milliards
de tomber sur quelqu'un qui soit
identique à vous une chance sur mille
milliards
c'est une probabilité quasi nul ces
hommes et ces femmes ont compris enfin
que lorsque vous prenez du recul et que
vous analysez la nature
vous vous rendez compte que rien
rien n'a été fait au hasard dieu dans
son léger n'hésitez à créer chaque pièce
unique
oui bien sûr et peut vous arriver de
tomber sur des pièces qui se ressemblent
mais vous ne trouverez pas deux pièces
identiques
je suis iv hui dirigeant et fondateur
d'une entreprise qui aident d'autres
entreprises à se développer à se
transformer sur le socle de la
performance mais il ya cinq ans j'étais
pas dirigeants d'entreprise j'étais
cadre financier dans une multinationale
en france une société qui est leader
mondial dans son secteur
dans plus de 80 pays dans le monde dont
j'étais en charge de plusieurs plusieurs
projets dans plusieurs pays et je peux
dire que ma carrière était en pleine
croissance
et si on fait
où on faisait l'analyse de ma vie basé
sur des références externe
oui on peut dire j'ai réussi dans la vie
et pourtant un jour j'ai décidé de tout
arrêter et de créer mon entreprise
pourquoi parce que je voulais donner
plus de sens à ma vie je voulais que ma
vie soit au service des autres au
service d'une cause commune
parce que j'avais compris une chose mais
qu'ils ont d'expérience professionnelle
d'alors aujourd'hui ça fait vingt et ma
formation 3ème cycle en finance gestion
1les et cultive à la ramasse business
school vous pouvez pas s'arrêter quand
ma seule personne
il fallait que je mette ses actifs au
service des autres au service d'une
cause commune et surtout au service
d'une cause plus grande
innover et s'engager pour la performance
des entreprises et surtout les
entreprises africaines
c'est cet engagement qui a donné
l'opportunité le privilège à mon équipe
et moi de pouvoir accompagner plusieurs
dirigeants de différents secteurs de
différentes entreprises de différentes
tailles et surtout de conseiller les
dirigeants dans la définition la mise en
place et l'exécution de la stratégie de
les accompagner dans des missions de
conduite du changement de formation sur
mesure en efficacité opérationnelle et
au bout d'un certain temps nous sommes
dit il fallait s'arrêter pour faire quoi
vous faire une analyse nous sommes dit
qu'il était important de faire une
analyse de ce qui fait nos succès et de
comprendre nos échecs
ah oui c'est important parce que dans la
vie il n'ya pas que le succès quel que
soit le type 2
professionnelle ou personnelle et ma
conviction c'est qu'on apprend même
beaucoup plus de ses échecs et nous
avons fait cette analyse nous sommes
arrivés à quelque chose d'essentiel que
j'aimerais partager avec vous nous
sommes rendu compte que nos succès
n'était pas nécessairement lié à la mise
en place de briand outils de stratégies
de gestion ou de performance quoique ces
outils soient importants mais nous
sommes rendu compte que le succès était
présent parce que nous avons pris en
compte deux éléments fondamentaux à
savoir le potentiel et le caractère
unique
je m'explique premièrement nous sommes
rendu compte que le succès était présent
parce que dès le départ nous avons su
identifier le potentiel et nous avons
mis notre confiance au potentiel des
personnes qui se présentaient à nous et
notre objectif a toujours été de
réveiller le potentiel qui était en
chaque personne et de leur dire allez-y
vous pouvez y arriver
en toute honnêteté vous avez le
potentiel pour le faire allez-y monte à
l'est encore plus quand ils ont atteint
des objectifs inégalée deuxièmement nous
sommes rendu compte que le succès était
là parce que nous avons fait du sur
mesure
nous n'avons pas cherché à copier les
autres
nous n'avons pas cherché à faire du
standard nous avons tenu compte de la
particularité de chaque personne parce
que nous avons compris que chaque
personne est différente et que chaque
personne est unique
quelle est la conclusion de cette
analyse
elle est toute simple c'est que l'homme
avec un grand h où l'être humain parce
qu'on jeudi à homs et l'homme et la
femme l'homme avec un grand h
un potentiel immense et il est unique
c'est la prise en compte de cette vérité
qui fait la différence
nous posons la question comment relever
les différents défis qui se posent à
nous tant aujourd'hui que demain comment
réussit notre vie dans ce monde en
pleine mutation
et bien la réponse se trouve dans la
prise en compte de ces deux éléments
fondamentaux
parce que la prise en compte de vos
potentiels me permet de me rendre compte
que je peux y arriver parce que ça crée
un dynamisme
ça me met en mouvement parce que je me
rends compte que chaque personne est
doté d'un potentiel quelle que soit sa
nationalité quelle que soit sa race dont
je me dis ah oui moi aussi je peux y
arriver je pense que les autres mondial
et montrer
on a vu un togolais qui a créé un robot
c'est pas un américain ni un français ça
veut dire que tout le monde peut le
faire dont le potentiel créé en moi le
dynamisme mais cela ne suffit pas il est
important de savoir qui je suis il est
important de réaliser mon unis cité par
le premier rang du potentiel malgré le
fait que nous soyons dans la quatrième
révolution technologique et que nous
soyons tous fascinés par la bouèze
robotique l'intelligence artificielle le
big data l'impression 3d en a parlé tout
à l'heure les véhicules autonomes
il n'y a rien il n'y a rien de plus
extraordinaire que l'homme l'homme et la
machine la plus complète la plus
extraordinaire qui soit
le robot le plus intelligent le plus
puissant ne peut égaler la profondeur de
l'homme car il ya tant à découvrir et
tant à dire
c'est ainsi que pour pouvoir démontrer
scientifiquement ce potentiel de l'homme
les chercheurs de l'université de
californie
des chercheurs en neurosciences en 2015
on fait une analyse sur le cerveau
humain
ils ont mesuré la capacité du cerveau
humain et déjà ils se sont rendu compte
que cette capacité est dix fois
supérieur à tout ce qu'on avait trouvé
jusqu'à là il savait pas et ils ont
poussé leur analyse plus loin et ils
sont arrivés un chiffre faramineux un
million de giga octet vous savez quoi
1 millions de gigabits et c'est la
capacité de stockage du cerveau plume un
seul cerveau et 1 millions de gigabits
et c'est l'ensemble des informations
qu'il ya sur internet
stocker quelque part ça fait un million
de gigaoctets c'est ce qu' un seul
cerveau peut stocker c'est
extraordinaire le temps me manquerait de
vous parler des différentes innovations
qu'il ya eu ces dernières années de vous
parler de la capacité d'adaptation de
l'homme car il ya tant à dire
cependant comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le potentiel ne suffit pas pour
réussir dans la vie surtout dans cette
ville en pleine mutation
il faut se connaître il faut savoir qu'
il faut réaliser son unicité
je dirais même son caractère unique
c'est la deuxième prise de conscience
que j'aimerais que nous puissions avoir
pour ce faire je me pose souvent une
question que j'aimerais vous soumettre
comment se fait-il que chaque personne a
une empreinte digitale unique
ce avec eux on peut identifier chaque
personne parmi les sept milliards de
personnes qu'il ya sur terre aujourd'hui
plus de 7 milliards je crois que c'est 7
milliards 4 on peut vous identifié par
votre empreinte digitale souvent mouassa
métriques je me dis mais pourquoi
pourquoi chaque personne à son écran
digital unique
si c'est le cas si c'est possible c'est
que vous êtes unique
si vous êtes unique c'est que vous êtes
particulier si vous êtes particulier
alors vous avez une mission particulière
à accomplir dans ce monde
malheureusement nombreux sont les
personnes qui ignorent ou bien qu'ils
passent à côté de ces vérités ou du
moins qu'ils les appliquent pas pourquoi
j'essaie de comprendre
essayons de comprendre tout ce pour quoi
et je suis tombé sur ça la fameuse
citation la citation populaire qui dit
la vie est l'examen le plus difficile
beaucoup de gens échouent parce qu'ils
essaient de copier les autres en
oubliant que chacun à une question
différente sur cinq copies donc vous
pouvez pas tricher chez les autres votre
question est différente c'est la prise
en compte de la mission particulière
attachée à chaque vie et du rôle que
chacun doit jouer dans le monde qui doit
être la solution des différentes
mutations auxquelles nous faisons face
les différents défis que nous devons
relever tant aujourd'hui que demain
c'est ce rôle que des hommes et des
femmes comme nelson mandela martin
luther king abraham lincoln
gandhi mère teresa pour ne citer que la
queue que cela c'est ce rôle qu'ils ont
joué dans ce monde et dans leur
génération
ils n'ont pas posé des actes pour
devenir des stars
nous vous savez ils ont juste pris
conscience que leur singularité leur
imposer une mission bien particulière
dans ce monde c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
posé des actes authentiques pour revenir
à la citation de tout à l'heure je
dirais ils ont juste répondu à la
question qu'il y avait sur leur copie
sans chercher à copier les autres ils
ont cherché à réussir leur vie et non
dans la vie c'est ce qui les a propulsés
dans l'histoire est la question que je
me pose et nous quelle histoire
où voulons nous écrire dans ce monde
l'histoire de ceux qui ont réussi dans
la vie ou celle de ceux qui cherchent à
réussir leur vie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]